- One of the most common
problems I hear about nowadays.
And I'm sure everyone else does
is this feeling of being chronically tired
Because sometimes it feels like
no matter how much sleep you get
you just can't seem to perk up,
feel energetic for most of
the day, every single day,
so that you can tackle your
day and your life with energy.
You know, this lack of
energy throughout the day,
this chronic tiredness is something
that you would expect to happen to you
if you were like 60 years
old, 70, 80 years old
but it's happening to 20 and
30 year olds, 15 year olds
young people who are supposed
to have this youthful exuberance to them,
but they find themselves operating in life
with a sluggishness and dread.
Believe me, I've been there.
I've been there so many times in my life.
So many times in fact,
that it really caused me
to dive deep and figure out
what are the things that are
actually going to contribute
to me having more energy
and how do I make those things
happen every single day.
And through all my research
and self experimentation
I've found out that the
most important things
are kind of the things
that you hear all the time.
Sleep, exercise, and diet.
You might be tempted now to
click away from this video
because you already know this
but that's exactly where
I ran into problems.
I was treating sleep, exercise
and diet like a checklist.
It's like, yeah, I get a
reasonable amount of sleep.
I exercise.
I'm an athletic guy.
Yeah, I eat food.
So those things can't be the reason
why I'm feeling sluggish.
So I started looking for
these like quick tips
and maybe I was iron deficient
or maybe I had a gluten sensitivity
or maybe I needed to
decalcify my pineal gland.
I skipped over the fundamentals in search
for some miracle pill that
would make me less tired
throughout the day.
It wasn't until I revisited the basics
and try to absolutely nail them
that I realized that was
the problem the whole time.
Especially sleep.
So in this video
I wanna go over some things
that I've implemented
in my life that really has
given me a lot more energy
throughout the day on a consistent basis.
And yeah, hopefully they
work for you as well.
- [Narrator] Are you always tired?
Do you move around the house?
Dreaming big dreams
but like the energy to
make them come true?
Well, maybe it's because you suck.
(bright upbeat music)
What the fuck?
- Okay, so thing number one,
I stopped misusing caffeine.
Now caffeine is one of those weird ones.
People think they know a lot
about how caffeine works.
You know, you've probably heard
that caffeine lasts between
five and seven hours.
So, you know, don't
drink too much caffeine
in the afternoon, or you might
not be able to fall asleep.
But the weird thing about caffeine is
that it lasts a lot longer
than five to seven hours.
The half-life of caffeine
is five to seven hours.
And half-life means that
after five to seven hours
half the caffeine is still in your system.
And then it takes another
five to seven hours after that
for half of that amount of
caffeine to leave your system.
So if you have a cup of
coffee at like 4:00 PM,
which is, you know kind of late,
but it's probably not
gonna ruin your sleep
or something like that.
Think again, if you have coffee at 4:00 PM
by 11:00 PM, there's a good chance
that 50% of that caffeine
is still in your system.
That means by like 5:00 AM.
There's a good chance
that a quarter of the
original 4:00 PM cup of coffee
is still in your system.
You know, deep into the night
is when you're supposed to be
having some of your deepest,
most restorative sleep of your life.
This is the kind of sleep
that helps you form memories
process the information
you were bombarded with
throughout the day, form connections
form new ideas, so that
you can be more creative.
The kind of sleep that's
supposed to be healing
your muscle tissues, purging your body
of adenosine so that you don't
feel tired in the morning.
There's a lot of important
things that are going on
while you're sleeping and
your body being filled
with this caffeine is seriously
inhibiting those processes.
So the simple tweak that I did
that helped me not misuse caffeine
is to just not drink
caffeine past lunchtime.
I have the one that I wake
up with in the morning.
And since I'm a little
bit of a caffeine fiend,
I have another one about
two hours after that
to really get my morning productivity
the kind of meth head
high that I'm looking for.
I'll still get the caffeine
crash late after lunch.
I expect that, it's the
kind of game you play.
If you're a caffeine addict like me,
but at least when I want to
put my head on the pillow
after a hard day's work
I'm actually able to get the
sleep that my body needs.
So do not drink caffeine past 12:00 PM.
Just don't do it.
The other thing that
I started implementing
was I gave myself a lot
more sleep opportunity.
Everyone's heard that you need
eight hours of sleep a night,
but the truth is in order
to sleep for that long,
you probably need to be in bed for longer.
I take about half an hour to 45 minutes
to fall asleep every single night.
So I need to be in bed half
an hour or 45 minutes earlier
than I'm planning on falling asleep.
And that makes sure
that I actually get the sleep
that I need every single night.
Because the benefits
of a good night's sleep
is something that's cumulative.
You know, if you give
yourself that much opportunity
every single night, your
amount of sleep baseline
will go up over a long period of time.
And you'll kind of work
off your sleep debt.
You'll work off your sleep deprivation
that you've been chronically plagued with.
All you need to do is give yourself
more opportunity to sleep.
The other thing that I did was
I fixed my circadian rhythm.
For those of you who don't know
your circadian rhythm has sort
of like this internal clock
that tells your brain whether
it's daytime or nighttime.
When you should be given energy,
and when you should slow
down and get ready for bed.
And a lot of your circadian
rhythm is dictated by sunlight.
How bright it is around you,
how dark it is around you.
Which is why you've heard
that you shouldn't go on
social media or on smartphones,
or look at screens right before bed,
which is very, very true.
When you're looking at
all this blue light,
your brain thinks that it's daytime.
So it's not giving you the
melatonin that you need
that your brain needs to know
that it's like time to slow
down and go to bed now.
So one thing that's really helped me
is to not look at screens
right before I go to bed.
And especially not in bed.
That way my brain can actually
start producing adequate melatonin.
You know, I can start
slowing down psychologically.
And by the time my head hits the pillow
during my little sleep opportunity window,
I'm out like a light.
The other thing I did to
fix my circadian rhythms
was I pinned a black
blanket over my windows
because I'm a barbarian with
no sense of interior design.
But what that did was
when it's the earlier hours of the morning
when I'm still sleeping, like
5:00 AM, 6:00 AM, 7:00 AM.
I still want it to be dark
so I can still be deep in sleep.
Getting as much high
quality sleep as I can.
Rather than having all this
sun blasting in the window
interrupting my hard earned slumber.
So make your room darker so
that for the time you're asleep
your brain thinks it's nighttime
and that you should be sleeping.
And the last thing that I
implemented to improve my sleep
seems like a little quick fix.
I don't know if this applies to you.
But I was reading this book
called Breath by James Nester.
And he talked about the
benefits of nasal breathing
as opposed to mouth breathing.
And I noticed that when I
put my head on my pillow
every night, my nose
gets really congested.
And I end up opting in
the middle of the night
to mouth breathing.
And in the book he talks
about how nasal breathing
is a lot better for you.
So anyways, if you can't breathe
out of your nose at night
fix that, I fixed it by
using Breathe Right strips.
This video is not
sponsored by Breathe Right,
but that's just what I did.
And they work for me.
I'll put a Amazon,
actually, I'm not going to put an Amazon,
like just type in Breathe Right strips.
Okay, so let's talk about exercise.
There is a fascinating link
between your psychology
and your physiology.
It seems like what's good for the body
is also good for the mind.
It's the reason why power
posing somehow, you know
like you're like standing up
and putting your hands
on your hips or whatever,
that kind of stuff increases testosterone.
It's bizarre to think of it,
but literally just power
posing, feeling powerful
lowers your cortisol, which
is your stress hormone
and increases your testosterone
making you feel more
confident and powerful.
And you hear so many accounts of people
who fix their posture
which allowed them to go about
the day with more confidence.
It's like a chicken or the egg thing.
They fixed their physiology
which translated into
benefits for their psychology.
The only reason why I'm saying this
is because one of the most effective ways
that you can have more
energy throughout the day
is to move your body.
- [Narrator] See how
the hips act as a pivot.
- You would think That if
everyone had the same baseline
energy to work with,
that if you expend that
energy by being active
you'll have less energy
throughout the day.
But the exact opposite is true.
People who regularly expend their energy
having a higher baseline
of energy to expend.
- [Trainer] He's tight with the buttocks
and slowly put the buttocks way back.
- It's almost like there's a golden rule
baked into the universe that says,
"That which costeth
energy, giveth energy."
I should probably make
a t-shirt with that.
- [Narrator] It wasn't
long before Ernie began
to feel the benefits of
his regular exercise.
- So you might be thinking,
Joey, you're an active guy.
You go to the gym, you play hockey.
So that probably wasn't that
big of a problem for you.
Well, it turns out it was.
I play hockey once or
twice a in the evenings.
And then I go to the gym for
like half an hour to 45 minutes
to do some heavy lifting
three to four times a week.
But I spend the rest of
that time by and large
sitting on my butt, editing videos,
writing content, whatever.
This sedentary lifestyle
was draining my energy.
So I made a simple tweak.
Not only do I make sure
I get out and take a walk
every single day, I do something
to get out of the house,
get moving, but I also
bought a standing desk.
So I spend a large portion of my time
when I'm being productive,
standing up on my desk
rather than sitting down.
And this has that power posing effect.
The fact that I'm standing
up my body kind of learns
that I'm more active and
I'm somebody who stands up.
So it's like here have more energy.
So use this weird phenomenon
to your advantage.
Make sure that every single
day you're getting up,
out of your chair you're going for a walk.
You know, a minute, every hour,
three to five minutes every hour.
If you're wanna be ambitious,
get up from your chair,
go for a walk, go do something.
The energy benefits will come in droves.
- [Singer] ♪ Take good care of yourself ♪
♪ It's so easy ♪
- And now just briefly
I'm actually not gonna talk about diet
because I feel like I don't
want to add to the noise.
One thing I've learned is that
it's really genetically dependent.
If your ancestors were from a
certain part of the universe
Maybe a Paleo diet works better for you.
Maybe you have a gluten sensitivity.
By and large though, avoid
packaged food, avoid sugar,
drink enough water.
You know, all these things.
There's a million diets
that you can look up on the internet.
If you're putting a
reasonable amount of effort
into what you're putting into your body,
and you're not taking care
of your sleep or exercise,
you'll probably still be sluggish.
It's the combination
of these three things,
especially sleep, especially exercise
with like a reasonable
effort put into your diet.
You'll have energy to work with.
You know, you'll finally
be somebody who is perky
who has energy, who can, who
can tackle their daily tasks
and actually get things done
without constantly feeling
like somebody is just dragging you down,
holding onto your shirt
and just like covering
your eyes all the time.
I don't think that was a terrible analogy.
I just want to give a
big thank you to Audible
for sponsoring this video.
And I actually only made this video
because I started reading the book
Why We Sleep by Matthew Walker on Audible.
It was just like a
really fascinating book.
Talking about the benefits of sleep,
the complex mechanics that
go on under the surface.
You know, it talked about
the mechanics of dreams
which is some Christopher Nolan's stuff.
And I'd highly recommend the
Audible version specifically
because the guy who's narrating it
has just such a golden voice
and you can listen to it
as you're drifting off into slumber.
And for those of you who don't know,
Audible is the leading provider
of spoken word entertainment
and audio books,
ranging from best sellers
to celebrity memoirs,
to news, business and self-development.
Every single month Audible
sends you one credit,
which you can spend on
any audio book of your
regardless of price.
Audible members also get instant access
to a bunch of news digests and
guided meditation programs,
which is also pretty cool.
And by far, one of the most
useful things about Audible
is that if you cancel your membership
for any reason at any time,
you still keep your entire
library of audio books,
including the books that you got for free
using their credit system.
So to sign up for your free 30 day trial,
either click the link in
the description below,
or text "betterideas" to 500 500.
Once again, to sign up
for your free 30 day trial
click the link in the description below
or texts "betterideas" to 500-500.
Thanks so much for watching guys.
As usual, if you liked this
video, make sure you hit like,
because the algorithm does it's magic.
It works its magic.
And it actually recommends my video
depending on how many likes it gets
and how many comments it gets.
If you're lurking here and
you haven't subscribed yet,
make sure you hit subscribe
because there's just, there's more of this
where this came from.
There's more of that.
There's more of this video where I,
there's more of me where I came from.
There's more where that came from.
(bright upbeat music)